well I want to solve the problem I
basically want to defend generative
systems so that they stay at the core of
our IT ecosystem Manhattan Project I
think in retrospect is an unfortunate
phrase what I meant by Manhattan Project
was a collective effort an effort was
some urgency and a sense of sacrifice of
actually being willing to take some time
apart from our day to day to make a
better system for everybody what I fear
it additionally conveys is a government
project to the tune of billions of
dollars carried out in desert labs in
secrecy that result in nuclear weaponry
none of that is part of the manhattan
project that i'm calling for so what i
say is it's time to realize that we
can't naively assume these problems will
solve themselves they will in a sense
the market will provide us sterile
alternatives and then problem solved no
more generative problems but also no
more generative benefits and I want to
see if there is a way to realize a sense
of community wherever the generative
problem was found that may help to solve
it and I I mean it sounds awfully naive
of me now as soon as I say the word
community but you look at something like
Wikipedia which is undeniably at this
moment useful who knows if it'll be
around two years from now it's entirely
possible it won't but wikipedia is a
collective hallucination it is an ethos
it's a sense of if you see a vandalized
page you should fix it and out of the
thousands of hits per minute the
Wikipedia gets the smallest fraction of
people embrace the ethos or even know of
it but that's all it takes as long as
there are more people feeling enough
identity with Wikipedia who called
themselves wikipedians and
obsessive-compulsive Lee instead of
playing solitaire that week or drinking
beer or watching TV or having an avatar
in second life or choosing to sit on
Wikipedia and argue about
whether it's Kim Jong ill or you know
should he be the dear leader or the
great leader depending on how he's
deemed or whatever it is they're arguing
about they are improving this
encyclopedia and they are outnumbering
for the moment the number of people who
want to subvert it or vandalize it and I
think that example of people undertaking
something not for money but for love or
for obsession or for fascination that
can be applied to other generative areas
like keeping the Internet itself open
well there's a couple things I would say
the first thing I would say to a group
of web developers is there are some
communities we can form together that
help us to solve some of the problems
besieging the free web so for example
there's an effort called stop web stop
bad way org that I've helped to start
it's at Harvard and Oxford University's
it's funded by Google lenovo sun and HP
and it has a couple projects one is to
develop a piece of software that anybody
can download that will relay the vital
signs of that person's machine back to
the rest of the herd and with it you
suddenly for the first time have but I'm
going to steal the phrase back from Bill
Gates a digital nervous system that lets
you tell what the health is in the stuff
attached to the internet right now
what's the weather like today how many
machines are actually rebooting hijacked
versus how many are perfectly happy and
you can measure that by the number of
restarts they're doing the number of
pop-up ads per interval there's some
rough proxies for it even asking the use
of the machine how happy are you with
your machine right now it also means
that before I run new code on the
machine that might be dangerous I could
say how many machines out there heard of
running this code right now how many
machines among people who have
self-identified as expert web developers
are running this code and it will turn
out the code like the Jessica Simpson
screensaver which comes bundled the
spyware is something that might be very
popular in the rank and file but not
very popular among expert web developers
like they have other vices than that and
to be able to easily share that and
aggregate that data together
is an example to me of a community
mechanism that can help people decide
according to their risk preference
what's good and what's bad without
having to turn to peter norton in a lab
coat or to the government FTC banning
stuff to decide what's good and what's
bad
you